hey guys alexa and mary here we are
gonna play the tomb raider dlc in our
brand new stream room that mary made
today it all happened and there's been a
lot of work put in by a lot of people
uh oh my gosh dan and tay and josh and
pretty much everyone in the live team
has worked tirelessly i put up these
sweet sound panels um yesterday um so if
there's any issues if it's um you know
if the audio isn't
loud enough yeah there's a problem we
can see you here we're working on it now
um and i'm happy to fix those things
come closer to me
get in here getting cozy out here this
is kind of scary so so uh this is all
this is all brand new and we're excited
to to do this for you and we're going to
start everything let me yay figuring all
this out as we go okay and we're going
to start with our brand new room by
streaming the brand new dlc yeah for
tomb raider baba
this is such a silly name but it is like
based on folklore i heard so yeah she's
exciting she's a witch so for those of
you i'm familiar with sorry
with the baba yaga mythos she's a witch
that lives in a house
that uh walks on chicken legs gross yeah
so
she's like
curses people into some terrible stuff
all right so well i'd love to get
started um so yeah i heard it you said
it was creepy i've heard it was creepy
so basically just you guys know um i
basically got
i start i got started just so that i
would understand where the heck we were
going
um let me go to the game now oh my gosh
this is so exciting and this is all
working we're um alexa's on chat so if
you guys have something to say you have
questions let us know we are streaming
this on the xbox one
not on pc pc goes live later this week
um we have it but we haven't we're not
streaming that yet so right now we are
just streaming the xbox one version of
this brand new dlc and here i am um this
is actually uh where there's an optional
tomb there's an optional tune in that
way and i went farther
and now there's this secret area so i'm
going to throw on these headphones so i
can hear but i can still hear you sweet
all right i love the the artwork in this
game it's just always so chasing grandpa
we're chasing grandpa right now that's
right i got this
this all happened
is this a new fire
uh i found this by
basically
running into a girl who was caught in a
locker she was like trapped in a walker
and she told me that her grandpa
went to get something and he's missing
oh this is story here we go
i have gone to seek revenge for your
grandmother
the voice acting in this game is so
clutch they do a good job um so this is
a new fire so now i have a new area oh
it looks like i have a weapon upgrade
available i'll do that real fast what is
it
compound bow well you know i always
thought i have i've been continuing to
play and getting more unlocks but i
don't have everything yet so like these
these tier you have to use money to
unlock that final tier so i haven't done
that yet
um but i've been trying
basically everything that's available
i've been trying to get it as i go but
there's a lot in this game like way way
more than
you'd expect oh to get it all you're
just talking about like so many more
hours and i was planning on spending my
christmas getting every unlock that was
actually my goal
but then i
started playing diablo again
all right sound bad choice we're all in
the same spot now
i haven't seen any of this stuff yet
we're in a brand new location so that's
where it came from there's this fire and
there's this upstairs area
super creepy some blood on the wall a
thing
yeah was made with the elderly native
male at
first we 0-700 he was participating in
an assault on the facility but he
proceeded away and threw an unmapped
canyon he's dead would this be her
grandpa
and already we've encountered ruins and
other promising signs
all right i'm getting it oh see like
i've seen this ivy throughout so i know
that this is encouraging we are going
oh
that looks poisonous
pollen
so the woman on the other side is nadia
on the walkie-talkie that's correct
um can we turn the game up a little bit
i guess people can't hear it sure
i'm gonna
make an active effort to try that
have you got a hot chewbacca asks have
you guys eaten chicken feet
mary have you eaten chicken feet you've
never eaten chicken feet i've eaten
chicken yeah you never go to dim sum and
have chicken feet
chicken feet are you know
oh are they looking at me they are 100
looking at you
all right here we go
i'm trying to turn it up a little bit
okay all right there's some spooking
happening
pretty creepy pretty creepy
as you all know i don't take spooky very
well
oh yeah this is like the ultimate oh no
dlc to play with you alexa oh grandpa
pop pop no
pup
no
wait
wait for me pop-up
i'm close enough i'm close enough oh
wait wait
is that her dad
shut up no yeah i think it's messing
with her mentally i turned it up a lot
but i might have turned it up too much
i'm gonna turn it down a little bit
sorry guys i'm we're figuring it out as
we go papa
if it's too loud let me know we'll
change it again not him daddy
i think it's the witch
oh it starts gotta get out of here it
starts it starts
that wasn't a witch house
i know what the witch house looks like
oh god there is a truth oh that was like
a centipede it's like a centipede big
centipede with glowing eyes
oh
this is
my house
this is super creepy this is laura
monner
asking why no face cam we are still
configuring this room so maybe at a
later stream
must be assured
it's a scared face
oh no oh no no no it's coming it's
coming it's coming
sunday
oh
oh my god
yikes all right it's the only way to go
i'm wearing my camo armor
there's the house
oh god
that is intense
uh i was told that the dlc is multiple
hours somewhere around three yeah i
haven't you know it was our first time
as a go through mm-hmm
jesus
um
um
i don't know what to say huh okay
there's fire now
fire is happening this is like an
in-game cut scene i can't move oh you
can't move not yet now oh now you can
move okay whoa
oh god those are these little like
mononoke wolves here
jesus
i unlocked this special fire that i
really like oh yeah this is like the the
not spoiling it but the special fire you
get towards the end of the game yeah the
game's been out for a while well
you know
trying to be nice there's so many of
them holy crap i'm gonna die
wow
considering like one hit you and you
were like already like in half half dead
this is crazy a lot of dodging here oh
look at that meat splatter
all right i need a new bow
i got that one but this one's gonna
the camera is a little weird here we go
all right i'm done [ __ ] around
jump
jump
whoa
damn
it's like chicken feet covered in boards
all right well we finished chasing
grandpa
great can you hear me how are you there
oh
she vomiting there's a lot coming out
that was a super long what happened
super long bombing said something about
flowers and pollen and then nothing i
thought the witch had killed you
i think anyone else want chicken right
now
ooh this really makes me want some
chicken wings you know there is a flower
in a valley that can bring on visions
but
the effects are too weak
all right that was pretty rad she's you
know
you see oh no no no i didn't jump far
enough
didn't kill me though um
you see a lot of dlcs that are just like
additional story but man they created
like a pretty intense character for that
yeah
man yeah
she's ugly
all right
i gotta be a bit more patient if she
doesn't give me
all right all right here we go yeah you
have to like wait for her to very like
do the animation mm-hmm
this is kind of x-files-y right because
she's like it's not possible
but then mulder's like
man i want to believe and then you end
up
seeing a witch house oh i would totally
watch
this that should be the new x-files
reboot it's just uh mulder and lara
croft
and she's like that's not possible and
he's all like
girl please
uh we're just running around like god
damn goddamn goddamn
recently
building on top of the ruins
what that
some sort of makeshift distillery oh
a distillery
this is a puzzle
if she can resist it somehow so there's
the turning thing
there okay i see so i probably need to
connect it to that thing so let's try
that
although can i get over there yeah i can
okay
i love uh the
combination of puzzles
no
dice
why do you want to connect it
yeah man
she did it
all right so that should pull it
and then
oh and i need to craft some of these oh
okay so we have a time limit here
so here's my thought
and you tell me what you think
but my guess is
that i'm going to
this gas like could be explosive maybe
maybe i mean it looks pretty it's pretty
gassy yep okay all right so here's my
thought
connect it
turn that at the right time
maybe
and then it will
and then it'll explode and maybe blow
that up yeah it's my guess i mean i
don't know i'm gonna try it here we go
now
nope too early too early
i got it
yeah man
you know there was i know
obviously we all really want to go in
there but i also saw this
over here do you think that oh just the
statue that's got to be something that
has to be maybe that's later
maybe there's just a secret back here
yeah maybe all right so you know it's
funny when you see stuff like that i
want to i want to go both places so
i never held my daughter they took her
from me on the surgeon's table
but they are many and i am really
then they dragged me away split our
three hearts apart three hertz they have
taken me to a hidden veil where ancient
ruins stand
they tell me if i cooperate huh i will
see my family again i will never trust
these monsters but i do not have a
better plan
there are curious flowers here exposure
to the pollen has left my captors
rattled and they will go no further than
our little outpost they brought me here
in the hopes that my expertise in botany
would help them find a counter agent
at last
the state has a use for me interesting
smile i play the part maybe this is her
cannot break me again
for my daughter
i think you're 100 right i think we're
starting to get the
bits and pieces to collect and
understand who
baba yaga is
i have a joke for you alexa what's your
joke mary
okay
did you hear
that lady gaga and the gugu dolls have
started a kid's band
no
it's called gugu gaga
mary
i'm actually holding on to that joke for
this exact moment
man in the chat my name is alexa yes
thank you okay very sensitive about my
name super appreciate it
oh boy oh alexis it's not alexa
although we had had an alexis here
before they have tasked me with findings
you did he's a nice he's a nice man
very nice
of the pollen that hangs in the air
now i believe i have a formula that may
work i might have to make this exact
from the seed pods of the plant
the liver of animals
and have metabolized the toxins
a phenylthiazine derivative
the last ingredient is a risk
in large okay
so i might have to get all these items
so that i can counteract the poison that
might counteract the effects of the
pollen and this weird it has to be for
my grandmother the witch killed her and
now she's gonna help save grandpa just
like in one of his stories save grandpa
i'm coming pop-pop
have faith laura gotta save my grandpa
i'll help you find what you love
also why does this girl not have an
accent oh but everyone else has the
accent
that's a good accent
save my grandpa
that's a good russian
you gotta skip a point
all right i have a new skill point
maybe i'll put it in survivor a fairy
tale
i just don't use
bullets
i never used bullets when i played
intellectuals
the bow is so op
the gunshot is still ringing
i like the way she says extraordinary
extraordinary extraordinary
oh we're back here we're back at the
beginning
cool
okay
so
i'm not going back in there without the
answer okay so
where am i collecting this [ __ ] from
inside caves and then we need two deer
livers
we're talking about not in here because
that's where it came from are we talking
about
backwards even farther
caves maybe like in
collect seed pods from capes maybe
are there a lot of caves in the soviet
installation there's a couple right you
can check the map
oh balls
that's so far away
boo
i was unaware all right so luckily we
got a
fire
so because of that camp i can fast
travel why don't you fast travel to
another camp in the installation yeah
so we'll like easily we'll like we'll go
there and we'll come back that sucks
though it's kind of like a fetch quest
i don't know what it is
i just want to shoot baba yaga's i like
the concept you know that they're giving
me more opportunities to spend more time
in this world i do appreciate that yeah
i'm just
no that's underground so we'll start
here
i wish there was an option where you
could just forge ahead without the
antidote and just like
work through it that'd be nice nobody
read this this screen because it's a
spoiler if you haven't finished the game
um somebody asked how many fx uh tress
effects points we've put in and it's so
funny because we her her hair does look
fantastic but we met the devs yeah and
uh it turns out they used a completely
different hair system than they did in
the original tomb raider so um like it's
called like hair power or something it's
completely different now uh so they've
oh too much vocal for me thank you let
me know oh they built a hair engine
for it i'm gonna turn mine down thanks
guys
all right
this is all a
test right now so you're learning and
growing that's right what you like this
is like our kind of first legit stream
any advice
okay first the seat pots the flowers
grow inside the caves are out
of them to make you there so you should
be able to gather some safely
the liver should be easy the deer are on
their feet on the flowers so you'll just
need to track them down
for the insecticide i have an idea where
we might find some
grandpa taught me to read russian so i'm
going through some old equipment
grandpa taught me to meet russia
but i don't speak it i'll start
gathering the other supplies now
all right so
they're giving me hints at least
that's good um
all right
so
let's see
it's up here to my right so we'll start
there there's a dead deer can you pull
it out of it oh i don't think so there's
a wolf cave up there like right there
i'm not i'm gonna be completely honest
with you it's a little bit of a
test for both of us because like this is
a cave right so maybe it's in here um
ice seems plausible yeah
and it's saving that's also
just need the seed pods now was it
behind you
is there something there
also yeah okay yeah good job so is there
a dude down there
there is i i can't tell if he's a friend
or not we're about to find out i'll just
go down hey buddy
you're back yep we could use you no no
i'm in the zone sorry goodbye good luck
all right so
is that a different cave i think it's a
different cave system so i think we're
going to
we're finding all the different cave
systems
which sucks
um
all right i mean i can't imagine that i
just ate the microphone i can't imagine
he just hit on me
it was his tone right yes hello there
hello there laura there's a difference
between hey and hey you
hello there
you're not flowers all right so
i'm just kind of going by the seat of my
pants here if you remember
where one is okay so to my right
and then right in front of me
maybe i have to jump across this thing
so i'll do that
i want to hang out with baba yaga i
don't want to
do some seed pod yeah because we've seen
so much of the soviet installation even
though this area is like pretty rad like
i've seen it so much i just like you
know i don't like this area anymore well
this was the only area we were allowed
to do like preview stuff in forever they
i must say they kept a like i was very
very surprised with the game like they
kept enough of it under wraps they did a
good job it was like super surprising
yeah in regards to like marketing i
can't stand it oh there's some flowers i
can't stand it when they give away all
the
secrets
i got something you'll want to hear i'm
patching you in
oh team is still m.i.a we haven't got
any transmission since the distress call
we're gonna need to send a rescue party
finish up your patrol around the soviet
installation see if you can pick up the
native girls trail she's involved in
bravo's disappearance somehow we need
better intel before we send more of you
in there
copy that
are these men look for grandpa i'm in
one of those old safe houses
so much effort for girls
i was wondering do you think it's
down here and to the right
uh that's my yeah because remember there
was one there there's one there's two
right there's one down there and one the
other way um
is
yeah there's one that way
i can't remember um
you have to jump across those i believe
people in the chat asking
is it free is this dlc free no it's not
this is part of the um season two season
pass and it's live today
um
i'm not feeling confident about this
i think you have to jump on that
thing and then
i don't know if that's true and float it
out i know see there's the cave over
there but why can't i just get on one of
those can you swim you can swim
she's gonna complain about how it's cold
for the next five minutes but you know
it is not out on pc yet i think pc comes
out friday friday
we're testing it right now in fact i
kicked um
tomb raider reviewer mike mccarty out of
this room so we could stream it and i
saw him playing it um
man it's so beautiful like they did such
a good job because you can play in 4k on
pc and
um you best believe
uh all right i have explosives you best
believe it would like
it's gonna like look better
in 4k
yeah i only have one left is this gonna
kill me
i don't think it shouldn't
oh jesus i forgot i have an add-on for
that oh it's basically every grenade has
mini grenades on it oh my god i forgot
grenade seption this is why i could
never be a demolitions expert because i
would without a doubt tell myself i've
never been in here before
yeah i don't think i've oh there's more
double dipping does that mean i don't
have oh no
[ __ ] what's down there
what is it what is it what is it it's a
[ __ ] bear oh oh of course of course
there's a bear
there's always a damn bear
but there's another set of flowers in
there how many do we need all right i'm
going back i just want to craft more
explosives you got that bear you got
that i think it was to be honest with
you i didn't see it but it sounded
bear-like did it not that was totally a
bear you guys
is it there
where is it
oh it's wolves oh
what those are easier to kill sorry i
thought it was a bear i got scared i
love the bear though
and they give you way more stuff
where are you idiot
i'm getting these flowers
i missed the bears guys i missed the
bears
[ __ ] this is a whole nother area to
explore
but
that's not why we're here as far as i'm
aware i think we're supposed to
keep going to all these caves
so i actually might
i don't think we have to go to all of
them i think we do because see look this
is saying um this is where i'm gonna
harvest a deer lover
uh here's another deer liver and here's
a cave
so all we need is one more flower um so
i think this is like other stuff that i
need
i'm pretty sure that they're gonna be
jerks about it
i'm pretty sure
i know i know
so i'm gonna leave this area
even though it looks cool game spot in
chat chating us make that antidote yaya
we're working on it yeah i don't i don't
want to do i could easily get
there's nooks and crannies everywhere
and i could beat some greens i could
probably
grandpa there's nooks and grannies
everywhere and i wonder if i can get out
this way
and i could explore this world forever
but i
i'm determined
oh i no i cannot balls all right we're
going back
swim lara
swim
oh my god oh somebody's saying team kish
for rocket league oh boy you best
believe also i think we're playing
today
uh i think the
third round
in uh the rocket league championship
starts tonight
i swim so freaking slow i think it says
you're we're going against the current
right now i know but there's no other
way to go
so i think i can climb out there which
is what i should have done instead of
jumping yup like an idiot
what a learning process
we've had today
don't you want to get out of the car
she's like ready to go did you see her
she's like
can't do it no more all right we're
getting there guys
um and my plan
uh i assume alexa is the same is we can
play basically until
they kick us out because the lobby
starts at 2 p.m
so what
all right so i think uh
i think um we're just gonna actually
just
we're just gonna keep playing until
someone comes in here and says please
stop yeah
we're just gonna sit here yeah forever
tomb raider
raiden tombs
so is it
oh sorry i know
okay so it's to my left and then on my
right all right here we go
so it should be somewhere on my right
coming up
yup
oh yeah realizing how much stuff i
actually haven't done i came back over
um after i beat the game i came back and
started raiding more tombs to beat all
the tombs but i mean i'm just starting
to see how much more
stuff there is in this game
you could really play this game for a
long time so like this save that i have
already beat the game this is done
she's pretty advanced and i have so much
stuff still break action shotgun piece
cool did you get the flower i did get
the flower so there's more also i think
behind you i don't know if you can like
double stock or whatever i might i might
try um
all right so
when we're done here
can i have some
can i have these no no all right we're
done bye those are the ones i got i
think
i
wish i could i'm trying she won't let me
all right maybe i'm done maybe i'm down
with flowers now i got to hunt some
ammos so
let's see where we're going
i know there's deer over there but they
want specific deer okay they want these
deer on my right
there are some very specific deer lovers
that we oh okay
that we need are these the guys looking
for grandpa
they're looking for grandpa with like
jet packs well now they're
dead and that happened really fast and
now i'm going to loot their corpse
all right looks like the only nooks and
crannies are in you
sure i don't know i'll let you have it
there's a rabbit i enjoyed it
um i'll keep it on explosives because
it's so effective
all right so
we are still looking for deer they
should oh no i passed wait is he just
like hanging out behind you
harvest deer livers this is an area
where deer spawn so i need to
find them
oh dear
dear yeah
i'm hunting for dia where is the deer
to find the grandpa
you should just speak russian all the
time
i can't do accents i have terrible my
accents are so bad they all sound
english no matter what i you know like
uh like an england
person like but then it kind of turns
into like a
weird like [ __ ] accent oh what's that
running in a straight line three wolves
running in a straight line as they do
are they coming after me because i have
a lot of explosive arrows with their
name on it
well looks like the deer aren't spawning
so i can always try over here yeah that
sucks because i'm already
i'm already here i wish the deer would
spawn
i wonder if they're not spawning because
of the wolves
maybe maybe you have to kill the wolves
those i mean there's rabbits why won't
there be deer
rabbits and squirrels look at the
squirrels i don't want those
those do not benefit me
oh my goodness let me know if you see
any deers cause i'll cut that while i'm
here
there's a lot of challenges and oh oh
what is deer we see deer two deer
get dear liver or make
i think i think i got him
because it gave me xp
oh my god oh my god that did it's like
oh no
it's like what no the deer is like
crumpled over backwards in a really
funny way and it made me laugh
i'm sorry that was really mean it's like
ah grandmother's notes
we did it you did it
they stored it in the lower levels of
the copper mill where they used it to
deal with the termites in the summer
the chemical grandmother's recipe
mentioned but i am not sure that it will
be safe to drink
okay the copper mill is here
um so we're going that way into the left
right
i'll head then now
damn skippy
sometimes they just make her fall from
great heights to get there faster
oh my australian is terrible
i can only say one sentence
say it
something awful happened here where's
the car
that sounds like boston
get in the cabin where's the car
that's it that's all i got
all right so what am i getting here what
am i looking for exactly
you're looking for
the like the termite the chemical
termite chemical
so maybe in one of these houses there's
like a bottle or something
there's a secret
okay i don't know if that has to do with
we now have heavy
okay so it looks
farther away so to the inwards a little
bit and to the left
so to get through this train station
because this is all okay so here we go
and then to the left
somewhere around here maybe
uh
what's out of the ground
is that oh that's an oil can to refresh
my oil
all right so i think i'm getting there
straight ahead
to find grandpa
papa
maybe in this room
so it's adapting it's like changing it
based on
what a good job i'm doing
hmm
so it could be in there that's my guess
no that's back where i started
balls
i did a bad job sorry i think uh
no it might
all right going this way maybe it's in
this house
kind of just
scoping it out
nope
mary what
you think grandpa's okay no
i think he like
i mean it depends on
how dark we want to go maybe he's in the
house and it's like that movie up and he
like refused to leave so when the witch
invaded it he was like he was like it's
my [ __ ] we're here we're in this
together then
all right so it looks like it's in here
that's what i want to say
i'm basing this off of my poor poor map
reading skills
okay i get it so i need to be up yup got
it
there you go
we know by by the game design in this
game that when you see a board with
white paint that's right it means you
can climb saying hey dummy come here
it's true like honestly is that it
no to maybe like
hmm uh how about that found it i'm
missing the ingredients now anyway on
that patrol
just picked
explosive arrows are open
ah so good there's i'm so strong now so
good
the huntress
is on the prowl where are they i hear
bullets
um but i don't see
grenada
oh oh oh oh they're on the roof
they're on the roof above me
is that what you said i think they're
shooting from the roof because they're
dropping
dropping mad nade bombs
i don't see them
oh they're shooting my [ __ ] body a
lot
yeah i saw a bullet come from that from
from your left because they hit me i
couldn't catch that
[ __ ]
once i find them i can typically kill
them
i'm just gonna find those [ __ ] first
gotta find them
oh there he is see what a jerk
whatever i love the sounds they say they
weren't up there they're down here that
was weird
oh here we go
we did it there's a lot of guns in this
game but i really like arrows i'm not
exactly looking forward arrows are fun
definitely if it does i'll make my own
and meet you at the beginning arrows
just want to have fun i'll let you know
when i get there okay
so did she say go back to the veil yes
okay so then what i want to do is i want
to go to this base camp
because that's the fastest because we
got we got the pods and the deer livers
okay cool so we are about to actually
be able to enjoy it
i'm excited
we've got some upgrades as well all
right i'll do those quickly because i
don't really care
i'm more interested in
wait hold on is it gonna make is it
gonna take like the deer lovers and [ __ ]
i'm worried that something we make is
going to take oh
that is a good
yeah question i would really think that
they wouldn't do that they wouldn't do
that because that would be
really bad on their part that would be
really rude that would be really
annoying
how dare you okay wait i thought there
was a camps is it this one is that the
closest the wicked veil yeah
i thought there was a closer one oh boy
let's go get grandpa
papa
i love you
nobody read this scream so once you get
the grandpa he becomes
your sidekick right and um he follows
you around and and gets resources for
you he fights the bears and if you get
really hungry um or cold you can cut him
open and sleep inside his belly
i think you're
what
the bear or grandpa
oh okay
poor grandpa
search the wicked veil for the witch so
enough for two doses got to make them
count okay so what does that mean does
that mean i'm gonna be timed i freaking
hate time stuff yeah that's
maybe not i don't see her
there's no counter
nadia everything looks you can't like
normal bring extra but nothing like the
last time
good
i've made my own antidote and enough for
grandpa if we find him grandpa i'm on my
way to meet you now
oh boy
okay
so interesting so she has two doses so
one's for her and then one's for grandpa
of course
yeah because they're planning on
bringing
grandpappy back
um it's interesting she's going to
i hope this isn't timed i would be
disappointed i don't think so there's
there's no timer i don't think that's
what they did here
this can't be the same place i was lost
in here it was the same place you were
just high
it's amazing how you can be to places
that you were like really messed up on
drugs with and then all of a sudden they
look like a new area
she doesn't remember my house was here
i passed it last time this is where my
father is there anything fun what's that
oh right story still alive in here it's
all wrong
lost the old man entering the veil
lost fisher lost parker just
gone
no trace
can't trust the eyes
seeing things
corpses
worse
things that walk so huge they hide the
stars i can't tell what's real
not sure there is a reel
is it the eyes
the eyes have to go what my hands are
steady now
billings goes first
stop uh hold still
you
gross the evidence would support
he stabbed out everybody's eyeballs what
do you know about these ruins
even before the witch made her home
there where people avoided the veil
the founders were building a shrine out
there but oh i can't happen for them
none of us have been in there in
generations
be careful even if your visions weren't
real that place is still deadly
all right oh that's where i'm going this
is now where all the wolves tried to
kill me
and now they're all dead laying on the
ground still where you left that's right
let that be a lesson to you
i left one of them behind
oh oh there's secrets everywhere i guess
that's to get home
yeah
all right so that's if i want to be a
wiener and retreat but that's not
happening
we're going all the way
or until someone tells me it's time to
end the stream
also um if for whatever reason we don't
finish this or something goes wrong or
one of us dies horribly painful deaths
uh i will most likely be putting up
gameplay of this later
this was something functional i see
ropes and wooden gears
the founders build lifts elsewhere
okay so it looks like i should be able
to jump on that nope too far
oh there's a secret back here though so
let's do that right now
someone in chat briefly mentoring
mentioning not tomb raider can't wait
for horizon zero dawn yes i also cannot
wait for her it's very similar isn't it
in terms of
lady with arrows to have been given the
responsibility of overseeing the
construction of a shrine to the apostles
out in the far vale the site is on the
very borders of our newly founded city
i'm gonna call it but that's very
interesting
um
still no crap
what's that i feel like that white like
i know sometimes because we've been
trained to assume that white means good
yeah i want to like but i don't think
that's the case i think this is a puzzle
like you said and i need to solve it so
let's focus on that
um so there's this tourney thing that i
should be able to rotate um
let's see okay so
maybe if i hit that and attach it
and then
turn it
something will happen
i'm a goddamn genius
um chad asking
when
no wait
rise of tomb raider coming to ps4
holiday this year
all right
i almost did it
i wonder if i wasn't fast enough or i
need a better system
um because here's the thing right like i
can connect that
to here and do it permanently so maybe
that's what i'm meant to do here yeah i
i think it's a fairly yeah fairly safe
pet
let's see
that would make sense right so okay so i
stop and then
now it should be forever
like a diamond
like a blood diamond
sweet all right cool
can
we
um b-boy maestro in chat asks so this is
coming out before persona 5. lol
maybe no probably not persona is
supposed to be summer i too i'm a
persona fan itunes reading with bated
breath hashtag john harden lied you know
um
riddle me this
so there's
others there's no ropes above us
so there's this guy
who looks
like it's the same concept of the puzzle
where's the turning the one that was
turning no so it's behind this wood and
i can't see it
see it yeah
hmm
i'm just looking for
something else that i can
turn
so there's that thing over there on the
ground um
i wish i could point to it i can see it
uh with that rope
but i don't see what it's attached to oh
there
there it is
so so i think what i'm doing
this is very interesting because i could
have done that from the ground so that
no no i guess i couldn't have no
their puzzle design is really good it's
fun and it makes you
go is that gonna oh i don't think it's
gonna hold
it's not so ah
wait wait
no it doesn't hold okay wait
look
it's going down in increments
and there's this white
and there's white there so is this the
kind of thing that's a
so i have to run to it really fast is my
guess
is that what's happening i think so i
think you have to jump jump jump and
then scrabble all right well let's give
it a whirl
lahar i think you i think we both know
what i want you to do here we go
do it for grandpa laura
go for ripple this is for grandpa
i don't think i'm gonna make it oh wait
and also how the hell do i get up there
oh i did it wrong all right we need to
think this through oh oh oh oh i think
this needs to go up higher maybe
do you want to go up there
because i think i think it's supposed to
go up there okay and then you go up up
maybe
right this is a good puzzle but
so
i probably could have made
these higher
should i have made them
can i jump
to
i don't think
can you can you balance on that like can
you get on the oh on the wood yeah i
don't think is that a thing
no
went right through it okay so do i need
to make these more even is that what
you're saying
so that is that your guess like look up
and to the right
like back up up here yep
like you have to that's where i'm
getting be up there that's where i need
to go
which means that needs to be higher
right right but if it's too high i can't
get there i can't get there exactly
hmm
what about that guy can that guy do
something what guy this guy this rope
right here sorry
this rope that i'm genderizing as a male
all right well i'm sorry i'm sorry i
don't understand what you're saying this
the other one the biggest guy yeah what
about it can we can that there's see the
rope up i don't know can that like
that's what i did to do this
okay this is the original puzzle right
so
so i i put this here
i
oh come on you
i that move okay okay i understand so
yeah what i want to do is make them even
so that i can get
so you can get up there to the other one
can you i mean can you get up there from
there i don't know
these are
these are the questions that we live our
lives but ah oh
i [ __ ] it sorry all right let's do it
again okay
you get a very limited amount of time to
make this work so my thought is
hashtag not all ropes i know sorry guys
go go go all right so
now they're even
see that so as long as i can get up
there which i think i can
i yeah
oh
no oh damn it all right so i don't think
that's it but so okay there's this
launch ramp here
which is interesting
uh i don't know its purpose yet
not like these
um see this see this
yeah making me want to jump
but it doesn't have a place yet
unless i can climb this rope up here uh
yeah well well well not only is this our
rope that helps pull the puzzle but it's
now my new transport vehicle very very
good puzzle design
by
crystal dynamics they have good puzzles
they they smart people all right so i
understand so now actually
because we have a new way to get up
there
i need to uh switch these all the way
nice so i get it now
good
good
you know i really i really love that
feeling honestly of solving these things
yeah i really really do i think they're
just they're so much fun to
to solve and then in between the the
moments of clarity when you go ah that's
what you wanted you little sneaky jerk
yeah and they're not like they're not
like oh gotcha puzzles like oh like this
is like super obscure it's like really
really
like really well done
and and it's the simple visual cues and
elements that they do most the time like
the the white paint and stuff like that
that just kind of helps yeah
yeah kind of helps you figure it out all
right so
here here we go uh see
what oh fudge so like see this like i
can't jump there still
i think you forgot to
set them
do you want me to set it higher is that
the plan because i thought i should just
make it as high as possible but it
sounds like that was the mistake no
maybe just lower it like a smidge damn
it all right sorry i thought i had it
obviously
still working it out
you know while you're while you're
fixing this puzzle you saw that brian
horton director of tomb raider went to
infinity ward recently maybe like that
yeah i think that'll work i think that
will totally work
i did see that and i'm gonna miss him
uh brian was a pretty cool dude yeah
oh god did it work it was too high again
maybe maybe bring it as low as you can
and then stand next to the rope and tie
your shot
tie your shot time your shot okay
i understand
so like bring it down and then time
yep yep yep yep yep yep yep
but yeah
that makes me excited for infinity
ward's call of duty because he's a
pretty good director
no go for it man
here they come
go maybe
i think yeah i i think you can make that
i don't know
maybe
yes no now we can use one of these ropes
to get back up
see she's giving us
she gives you audio
clues when you when she doesn't believe
that
i love she doesn't think
listen listen stupid i'm just doing a
test run to make sure i can make it
that's all
all right cool
we did it
uh woman in chat asking could can i can
you buy the game with all the dlc
included um this dlc is part of the
season pass so i'm pretty sure that for
pc and for xbox there's an addition
where you can buy
the game in the season pass all at once
but this is the first piece of the
season pass dlc
oh sorry
you know i think it's x i have the rope
ascender that makes it faster
sorry i actually haven't picked this
game up in a
little bit
i was telling yeah i was saying that
earlier like my plan was to play
here we go my plan was to play the crap
out of this game and then i started
playing i started a new character in
diablo and i got i got distracted but
it's very good still i remember it it's
like riding a bike or something
or something
all right so here we go so this is the
timed one so my goal is to
get there and scramble up that wall
oh okay oh my god you're totally gonna
make it
no [ __ ] all right i'm not gonna say
anything next time
but that's it but that's like that's
what you yeah i did it i just need to
execute it now
wish i had a rope ascender up there
i know right
i missed it by like like a second
probably if i didn't uh mess up that
first jump i think i would have done it
oh come on
here we
we go there we go there we go there we
go there we go
and you keep eating the mic keep like
bumping into it sorry
all right come on girl
i talked to her like a old dog
come on old girl come on girl you got
this
we've been through so much
can't give up
yay
shut up nadia
you've been behind me this whole time
nadia's hanging out in a valley
somewhere just like uh did you like get
the
did you get the thing yet because i'm
like getting bored yeah as soon as i as
soon as i kill the witch she's gonna be
like i'm here
oh i'm here i did it we did it sure
what this is for can you pull it is it a
lever
it maybe
well i was thinking maybe it was a way
to quickly get up here in the future
it's a lever it looks like a lever
i uh
whoa whoa hold on
wait
is that
look at that nadia the witch has kept
the lift running well well well it looks
like she even made a few improvements
but one of us did all the work
seriously it only needs to make one
two
i'd like to come back down
actually nadia who who's whose grandpa
taught her to learn russian who lives in
a soviet installation who doesn't
cannot speak russian at all
it's a gondola yeah how does she survive
right
girl did you like study abroad or
something like what's now i have to
defeat the witch
i was just looking
i was just looking if there was any
um
secrets or goodies
but it looks like there's
oh okay no goodies i'm assuming this
lever does both right
so when i push it
yeah
how did
how did nadia get up here when laura had
to like squeeze through rocks and swim
and climb and naughty is just like oh
hey i rolled up with my giant backpack
like movie magic hey man
yeah she's
what a freeloader
i miss sophia
jesus it's clever
everything in this veil is arranged to
perpetuate the myth of baba yaga the
poland does the rest it's last time okay
look nothing like this
what did you see
just as a legend says
house walking on giant bird legs but
chicken legs without the pollen it's
just an old contraption
i'm sorry
i was so sure
she's russian someone who knew the myth
well
nadia it's okay i feel like your
grandfather will know who she is he was
a prisoner in the gulag you said sorry
i'll keep the camera still i just want
to look at everything
my grandmother was the prisoner
and they brought her out to the veil to
help study something
okay
this is very beautiful
yeah that's something i just like at
this point i'm just
like a spoiled child and if it's not
beautiful i'm like wow you guys really
messed up i expect really beautiful
environments
because of the last two games i just
everything they make is so many really
great job it's gorgeous and if you guys
like the way it looks now like i said i
saw i saw mike playing the pc one and
hot diggity dog 4k looks nice we're
gonna put some 4k footage up as well
sweet it's not agent wait hold on it's
nadia just going to like hang out in the
house am i going to meet you later
girlfriend see you
when you're do everything i think i saw
a sparkle up here
you and your weird ass tablecloth i did
my eyes don't lie
um
yeah and it sounds to me from what laura
was saying to her was um the poison is
making people believe they've seen we
found grandpa
this grandpa
oh
it's the pollen
here let me what's on his head
you're super high grandpa
nice tat grandpa
i tried
i couldn't save her
i
okay tried i'll stay with him oh my god
oh conveniently nadia's gonna stay
behind with grandpa
make it count
you suck all right bye nadia hi grandpa
yeah so oh good i got a new base camp
which is really nice um sweet i'll
i'll sit here you got a skill point as
well great um what i was saying was i
think um
laura was saying that i didn't actually
there is no actual witch it's the drugs
that made us think that that house was a
witch so we actually
i guess i'll do that i guess
yeah so she's kind of being the skully
right now and debunking the fact that
there is no
there is no mystical baba yaga there is
no house witch that was just something
that people thought they saw because of
all the acid yeah
she flip-flopped there she was the
molder working in the glue because she's
the scully i would lash out a stolen
screwdriver misplaced paperwork futile
gestures that would never balance the
scales one day
i was caught taking a stupid risk your
grandmother seraphima she spoke up took
the blame
they beat her
mercilessly but i was saved what when i
found the moment to thank her
she spat at my feet
told me i had the troubled marriage well
nothing
she gave me no credit for my little acts
of disobedience
that place the gulag the gulag all right
i feel like i got it we got it grandpa
we had a real tough time
if you guys like it and you want me to
keep
doing that i will 100 keep
uh
keep doing the stories yeah i will like
play through all of it but in the sake
of for the sake of me trying to um
play through this somebody today
somebody had mentioned my laura looked
real fly and i'd like to say thank you
that's her camo look i have a few i
don't have a lot i'd really like more
she um i mean oh god that's not i
remember oh my god i remember we played
this game was it at was it when we were
at crystal or was was it when we played
it at the microsoft event because you
put laura in a tank top and she looks
miserable and it stressed me out she did
it's in the very beginning of the game
when she's like really cold and she's in
the uh
it's before you get to the encampment so
you're just like straight up in the in
the snow wilderness and it was before
they fixed it so i put her in a little
tanky and uh she like roamed around in
the yeah no he blizzard in a tank top
and she and her teeth chat like if you
stopped to look at her her teeth were
chattering like they do a really good
job building her up
oh here's a corpse
bravo team bravo team bravo team is here
bravo team i thought she was saying like
bravo good job team no because nadia is
just so useless that's where i'm gonna
come out of
i love how they do that they're um
whoever makes their lovable design they
do a
there's a pretty
pretty good job of letting you
come back the way you started they're
almost always
oh boy here we go can we take the
antidote i don't know i mean i can't do
it on my own she has to do it
no
i need that last antidote all right take
it then
dummy
i assume she did it i have no idea of
knowing
well she said i need my i need it so i
think she's holding on to it
this is the last of it oh i broke the
bottle lick it
lick it off the floor
two second rule she looks so sad
all right this is a puzzle boss isn't it
oh my god
oh
yep dude baba yaga is ripped look at the
arms
okay this is really cool actually okay
and she's got the rope around her which
i mean i yeah oh that's cool
so i'm assuming you have to pull her
over and then like you did in the
beginning you have to blow up i would i
think you're right i think they're
testing me and preparing
i think they're
getting in the water i think they're
testing me and they do that a lot i've
seen this in the game is they give you
something that's training you for uh
something you're going to need later on
oh that was so sneaky
good game design i feel like you have
this game
oh my god
yeah man you ice picked that theater
that's right don't
get near me i'm gonna kill you
all right so here we go
there's still a guy over here
there we go bye bye
oh all right let's just shoot some
fireballs oh
that just baba yoga things
all right i'm not sure what i'm doing
you gotta explode that
okay
wait she said something
yeah she said explode the thing no oh
that's not what she said she's saying
she's giving me hints here i need to pay
attention
god
you [ __ ] all right i'm gonna do it
again but listen to what she's saying
she's giving us audio cues here
i have to stop her from cutting the rope
that's what she's doing
so is that
is that me hitting her or
i'm assuming if you shot her she would
maybe stun
oh i missed by so much
dodge
and then maybe
maybe this is there's other stuff to do
on the other side here i'm gonna grab
grab some stuff
and see what i can do this is really
cool
dodge
she's got a lot of freaking ammo
and it's really annoying yeah
did i hit her
i have no idea
i mean
jeez whoa dodge
okay did they do it you pulled her over
oh so you can pull her as well
that didn't work though this is the
worst game we've cut the rope ever
all right let me think let me think let
me think all right so i think we're
doing it fine
i think what i need to do
yeah it's so hard to dodge so
i need to open this thing
and that as she's over it yeah and
that's
where how do i do that though
okay so that's opened by over here
remember you got it all right so all
right we're doing the same thing i got
it okay my brain just kicked in
[ __ ] it's gonna hurt all right so i'm
gonna go shoot her
did i shoot her
oh all right sweet nice all right so
there's one now i gotta do it again
and you can also pull her over
like you can shoot her and then like
pull her over
i gotta
laura's got potty mouth
wow all right so i did it twice
um
oh i love it when boss plates change
all right she's still alive
old skank
yeah but she's jacked do you see her
arms
totally ripped
some healing stuff
i forget
all right i guess i don't need to go
is this right am i supposed to go this
way
i'm assuming yeah oh
oh man oh wait i forgot to do the right
thing
whatever do the right thing
do the right thing
they gave me that can for a reason and
it
wait
what is
i don't know that noise was gross ah
love the sound design here they gave me
that can for a reason and it wasn't to
throw it at them it was to construct a
bomb and i didn't do it because i'm
[ __ ]
right now i'm airy you don't sell
yourself now i have a bomb
take that have a can
if you think i won't blow myself up
you're wrong
i'm wiley
so that does that i think i must be full
yeah
yeah all right whatever but elvis
all right am i going this way into this
darkness
no
wait there's eyes in there
hi i'm a guy going up hello
okay
hi
yeah okay so round two
oh dude there's some dudes here
whoa
i see you
peekaboo [ __ ] i saw your little skull
oh no oh geez i'm trying to loot here
lady give me a minute what's your prob
all right so is this the same con it
looks the same concept to me you pull
her over and then
blow her up all right
no wait this art direction is just
awesome
oh come on there we go
so she's gonna try to cut it
um i guess that's pointing me towards my
no i thought it was i thought it was
telling me what to do next but i am
wrong
um i think you can climb up there yeah
this looks right
feels right it feels so right feels so
right
what's in the box
what's in the box
all right here we go here we go here we
go
are there any more bad guys oh i'm
confused i think
i think she might be running solo
what am i doing oh oh wait wait if you
go back and look there's one of those
little gas pits to your left
left more
like over there see with the turtle
that's turning
yeah i see it so am i not supposed to be
up here yet
is this later maybe
we might have jumped the gun here
all right so it seems like maybe we're
supposed to be going in the other
direction over here
i don't know i'm not basing this off oh
oh can we go down there and then go that
way and up is that not where we came
from am i not
i'm assuming we have to get there
that seems all right
let's try it okay
because i thought that's where it came
from i guess it's not
a plus to sparks v in the chat dropping
the baba yaga origin story oh what tell
me
um
so uh
in russia and post-soviet countries
parents tell their children legends of
baba yaga to scare them so she's sort of
like a boogeyman and i guess there's a
bunch of lore attached to her i'm
confused is this right this doesn't seem
right
yeah i don't like why would i climb this
in an emergency
like i'll do it it just are we
yeah leave the area i did but the music
is still playing
it just felt weird um
oh you [ __ ]
she's like right there hanging out
all right this is right
okay
oh
my god
all right i'm gonna shoot you because
you're uh oh my god what is happening
right now oh oh moving platforms here we
go here we go oh i can't make that i
don't feel right
oh don't you laugh i laugh yeah
i got her where am i going that's where
i was right yes okay so i want to go
to where that guy is
are we gendering all of the objects in
this game
that guy
oh jesus okay
oh my god no i know he's going to kill
me if i don't get my [ __ ] together you
can heal up
whoa
i keep stopping moving oh my god
i would prefer your russian than your
valley girl which i really don't enjoy
do you know where i can get a smoothie
around here
all right here we go here we go you see
what she's wearing all right got it okay
all right so scramble
scrambled pipes
all right here we go
i'm in fire i'm in fire
i'll tell you what i know enough to know
fire bad fire pad
oh okay here we go
this is such a visually interesting boss
fight
fudge fudge
all right i'm not close enough to the
rope because i got it that time all
right
all right
here she comes
all right where's the thing that i
where is it uh oh
oh i did all that for nothing wait is it
right there how do i open it
oh it's there oh my goodness oh stinky
sneaky sneaky butts all right no worries
no worries no worries noise
who built this facility
yeah what was the original purpose of
said facility
all right she's gonna try to cut it
all right i got her
oh my god
that was clutch that was super fun all
right cool i thought that was the end of
it but it's still going can you hear me
oh oh are you on your way
oh nadia
he says
he says it's her laura the witch is my
grandmother she's alive
i'm gonna kill her spoiler
i'll do what i can but we have to end
this nadia
nadia
nadia you
whatever no no i don't want to hit that
ah [ __ ] it
yeah
so sometimes when i jump in games it's
like i'm playing a uh
i kind of like do it as if i was a
tennis person
did i hit him
nope missed
[ __ ]
nice
all right there's a lot of them oh
two that was
wow wow those uh gut pieces bounce real
far away yeah well
i like
bad guys
like my soup
chunky
uh all right somebody else is shooting
at me
that guy
bye
okay
all right so
i think we got one more of these no i
don't need a can all right so is it up
here is it the one that we were at
before that we weren't supposed to be at
yet
oh you're probably right
yeah
let's go up here and see
see what
doing pretty good though yeah
i think you
are right
yep
good call alexa
down in front
all right so when this pla oh it's
already up again
is she ducking
oh my god
down
yeah look at these jerks don't they have
anything better to do
crap i was supposed to jump onto that
wasn't i
all right well i missed
i mean
can't you just hit her
no i mean i need to get on this platform
so i gotta wait for it to go around all
again which is annoying so i'll just pay
attention this time
it's so distracted
by all the lights
and all the moving pieces
so good though
it's great i'm having a good time
i'm having a good time all right so i'm
confused
so it's there
i don't know if i can make that um
should i just jump
i don't oh okay
take the wheel jesus
oh my god they're everywhere oh i'm
gonna die no no no no no you got this
you totally have this you totally have
it
i totally have this all right hide
okay i'm out do you have um um
healing
i'm all right
all right all right so
she's gonna throw some shiz at me we're
getting there
this is a long long fight yeah
uh all right so
this is like mentally exhausting all
right so here's this and then here's the
opener all right so this is i hope it's
assuming i would assume this is the
final one because i've been
no nadia nadia says it's her grandma's
try not to kill her
although
that's just not how i play
oh was that too soon i did and also i
didn't stop her from i didn't stop her
from cutting the rope sorry i keep
i'm in the zone so i'm like
all right here we go i got it
did she
i hit her but
[ __ ] oh my god
there we go
sorry grandma
she's so dead
sorry jima
look look at how jacked she is look at
those arms that's the kind of grandma i
want to be
jack you'll totally be a jacked grandma
stop and no more
i know who you are
i can only imagine what you've gone
through to stay alive
you have no idea
it's over now you have not you don't
have to live like this anymore you're
jacked you could do so much with your
life
grandpa
you died
mama they told me you died
they told me
will she be all right
god damn
learn some russian
drugged out old couple
oh i know maybe take the gloves off
before you fondle your husband
no okay no he's like no leave them on oh
she's
oh
oh
all right
i think
i mean i don't know i assume that's it
it's her
always been her
at the margins
in the dark
always there
she
she is what we came here for we just
didn't know it until now huh all right
so there's some creepy uh
creepiness so that's the uh
that's the entrance
so
dream stinger what is it what is it
dream stinger bow infuses your poison
arrows with hallucinogenic pollen
oh man oh it gives a confusion
poison arrows all right so i want to
kind of test this out so you don't you
don't have to finish the main game
to unlock baba yaga if it's available i
don't know it doesn't seem like it
because um well you obviously have to
progress enough in the story that you'd
be able to access this part and i
accessed this about
i want to say halfway through the game
maybe even less than that because yeah
it's in the soviet institution it's
before you get to the um but so you have
to understand but you have to beat it i
think well there's skills that you need
to get to this area in the soviet
installation like you need the um
the rope pull
so
i don't know
because i imagine
those um
hallucinogenic arrows would be amazing
in some of the later
they're
levels
we all are but it will be difficult it
will feel impossible some days i know
at least they'll have a fighting chance
did we do it was that
that's it girlfriend we beat it all
right
good job it's interesting yeah they said
it was uh
it could been around three hours and
maybe maybe there's like remnants let me
look at the map
yeah there's gotta be a lot more
but i just beat it in an hour and a half
i mean i'm good but
i don't know if uh
it's grandpa i think that i think that's
it
we saved grandpa we saved jesus do we
get a new costume
it didn't say that i unlocked anything
like that oh my god as far as i'm aware
i would love like a baba yaga costume
for laura
running around
just running around
just by by yoga
i think we beat it nice i'm gonna call
it um
obviously if there's secret extra stuff
they didn't do a really good job at
explaining it um but i would think that
that's it i think we just beat it yeah
um all right so i'm gonna go back to
camera flawlessly with no issues oh that
was awesome
so
that was uh come closer to me again
you're always drifting from me
i want you i want you near me so yeah we
just beat
baba
so to be fair i played um a little bit
before we started streaming not a lot
like 15 minutes
so
um you got right into the like you had
to get into the cave and find the area
beforehand yeah so
um you know it's it's not about two
hours less than two hours but there's
secrets in there i think that could take
you longer and like i said i mean when i
was in those cave systems i was finding
other things that i'd never touched
before so like there's just so much to
explore in this world that there's
potentially more yeah and i think they
have
one maybe one or two more like i know
they're doing other expansions like baba
yaga for laura i know they have a pretty
packed i guess plan for
tomb raider so
i can't wait to see what else they do
that boss fight like how about that boss
fight yeah that was rad and i i think
like
the whole world was really fun i've seen
some hit or miss dlcs and um like i was
i played like the uh
the batman dlc it was so quick and i
didn't see like new environments and
new stuff like i love the fact that we
went to a new area they created
something new the poison um
vines or whatever and then um kind of
this like hallucinogenic
area i love hallucinogenic darts or guns
or whatever like i love sewing that kind
of chaos you like hallucinogens
are you you want to party yeah let's go
party all right now that we did the
stream i can't believe it we just found
out uh it turns out everyone was on
drugs
the whole time
but that's that's it i'm gonna take
these off i don't need them anymore it's
very beautiful it's beautiful gorgeous
it was gorgeous and i had a really good
time i hope you guys did too um
coming up we are not done um we are
going to be streaming the lobby at 2 p.m
today yes sir just like we have been for
the last month um this might be
our last lobby in the vo booth because i
think our set comes
this week i heard our set does come this
week which is very exciting so uh if you
guys like this kind of stuff stay tuned
we will be live again at 2 p.m pacific
for
the lobby and we have all sorts of
really good stuff to be talking about
with you guys there and until then uh
this is
me mary and alexa
signing off thank you guys for joining
us thank you and you guys oh wait you
know what i know how to get our little
names up names names names names
there we are yeah you guys can check us
out and uh tweet at us and let us know
what you guys want to see more of
because now that we can stream in this
fancy new room we can be streaming way
more so i'm looking forward to that and
uh i hope you guys enjoyed this it was
really good hanging out with you thank
you for spending the morning with us ah
good morning it's afternoon now i'm
getting some lunch all right bye
i it takes a while to undo